so here's kershaw the 32 year old wonder
kid
10 starts this year six and two in a 216
era everybody knows what it's been like
for him
in the postseason there it is strikeout
number one for clayton kershaw caught by
his buddy
austin barnes
two-two breaking ball strike three see
you later christian yelich
beating into the ground right at seeger
and that'll do in the first brandon
woodruff all
set to work to mookie betts
seeger will follow and then justin
turner in the dodger first setting
well mookie thought mookie called
himself out i mean i thought mookie said
i think i'm done and jim reynolds then
was appealed to and he called him out
and he blew him away 98 miles an hour
and what a start
for brandon woodruff tonight
this one into right playable and that is
tyrone taylor
and are moving on and the pitch
that got him looking on the outside
corner third strikeout for woody
he's already got three strikeouts
there's number four's bellinger chased
go ahead run standing at second base
the pitch is a swing and a miss he went
with the slider and garcia
has seen six pitches in this game and
has not made contact
two and two to count on pollock and
woodruff coming back
struck him out looking fastball in the
outside corner at 97.
strikeout number five for brandon
woodruff kicks and throws
and he struck him out threw him a change
up over the outside corner and betts was
frozen
two more strikeouts in the third for
brandon woodruff he's got
six in the game leading off in the
fourth we're scoreless
kershaw to jerko swung on and missed
strike three
swung on and missed strike three slider
two strikeouts for kershaw in the fourth
five in the game no score after three
and a half run down bottom four
two two to turner
change up caught strikeout number seven
for woodruff
oh my goodness brandon woodruff
eight strikeouts through four and
instead of flipping bats they're tossing
helmets right now in frustration
there is a first base the lead-off
single kershaw said here's the pitch
taylor swings and misses and he is down
on strikes
that is the sixth strikeout of the game
for kershaw one out one on
kershaw delivers fastball ground ball
backhanded stabbed by taylor throws to
first
he gets hurries and the pitch
swung on and missed strike three and
that's going to end the inning
seven strikeouts for kershaw now is all
set to work nottingham sitting down
blowing away in the pits
got him looking another very sharp
slider that time and
smith is gone pollock with the dodgers
first threat of the night bellinger
leading from second taylor from first
both with great speed
two beaten on the ground nice play over
there at third fires across the diamond
it's scooped and dropped
orios threw it short and jed jerko tried
to scoop it but couldn't
so they only get one instead of the
double play and this dodger team you
don't want to give away free stuff
barnes a single in his first at-bat
first and second two out still scoreless
woodruff set now the pitch
barnes up the middle into center field
for a base hit
rounding third on his way home standing
up is taylor
and the dodgers take a one to nothing
lead austin barnes is two
for two so now first and second two out
and mookie betts coming up
that's on two and oh bangs one down the
left field line is gonna roll into the
corner
pollock will score barnes rounding third
he's on his way home and he will score
mookie betts delivers the dodgers given
an
extra out to work with capitalize they
score
three it is now three nothing done no
teams ever gone to the playoffs
having never been over 500 for even one
day
kershaw continues to pitch well he picks
up strikeout number eight
here's the one two to yelich swung on
and missed strike three on the breaking
ball
that is strikeout number nine for
kershaw two out nobody on here in the
sixth
and jed jerko coming up two balls two
strikes two out
kershaw to jerko call
strike three that's going to end the end
and kershaw strikes out the side
double digit strikeouts on one and two
they're a curveball call strike three
uncle charlie on the scene 11 strikeouts
for kershaw who is pitching a
marvelous game tonight taylor from
torrance
swung on in miss strike three clayton
kershaw has struck out an
even dozen hasn't walked anybody
nope that that means did you stay there
i'm good you stay right
right where you are i've earned it
got him leaning did he get him he got
him
called out is oreos here it comes
and down he goes strikeout number 13
for kershaw fabulous performance tonight
for clayton
a pitch to ben gamel he swings and
a fly ball to left field taylor is there
he's got it in the dodgers two wins down
11 to go in search of the elusive
1988 curse they just want to get rid of
it once and for all